okay
this was the demonstration French
authorities tried to stop
eleven days after the killing of 17 year
old nael by a policeman in the suburbs
of Paris the sister of another man who
died in police custody in 2016 continued
her fight for justice
we have always demonstrated peace
today the police department s blocked us
on the
armed events
Professor triore had to break through a
police Cordon to carry out the protest
cheers held every year since her brother
adama's death only this year the
authorities refused permission
they were fearful of further rioting
that has swept France in the past week
and a half
that didn't happen some pepper spray was
used and troyore's brother and another
man were arrested before the
demonstration broke up
with the March over the organizers have
gathered here where they told us their
actions were a success and they
denounced the police for trying to stop
them police say they will prosecute
assatriore for not formally declaring
the demonstration we yes French police
are violent people talk of these youth
who Rebel at night but we want to say to
them let's build our anger together
let's build ourselves come and walk with
us let's talk let's organize let's find
solutions to these problems without
resorting to violence this March was
originally planned for the 19th of July
but was brought forward to keep the
spotlight on the police in the wake of
Niles killing police now fear next
week's basti Day Celebrations could be
another Flashpoint Polaris Al Jazeera
Paris
still ahead on the bulletin